[Music]
joining me today is the co-host of speak
for yourself on Fox Sports one and a man
who has no problem speaking for himself
Jason Whitlock welcome to the Rubin
report glad to be here I wanted to be
here big fan of yours they love what
you're doing
Thanks well I feel the same way we had a
strange interaction on DMS on Twitter
where I invited you on the show not
understanding that you actually do live
in LA you're here we could have had your
months ago but your timing is good
because at the top of the show I was
talking about people getting in trouble
for speech and this is something you've
consistently managed to do yeah I think
anybody that particularly now previously
it used to be celebrated in the media
but now it's pretty much derided anytime
you say anything that doesn't go along
with group thing people over social
media get irate and I've seen my entire
industry I'm someone that still
considers myself a journalist although
I'm doing broadcasting now but I was a
big fan I grew up idolizing my croco at
the Chicago Tribune and he became a pure
surprise winner became very successful
in this industry because you could not
predict his position and he just came
across this honest and fair and whether
you liked him or not in the position it
came from a real place and I've seen
this industry if Mike Royko were alive
today he would not be successful yeah
you have to be populist and preached to
acquire to be successful in this
industry isn't that kind of crazy and
considering that you're in the sports
industry now I know you talk a lot about
politics they're going to get into a lot
of your opinions on things well you're
in the sports biz which you should be
allowed to say what you want because
you're not sound like you're dealing
with abortion on a day-to-day basis or
gun control things although a lot of
these things have now seeped into the
sport conversation but when you started
this did you ever think that you were
going to end up stuck in this place of
you know not you're never afraid to say
what you think but stuck in this place
where that would be in
I'm totally shocked because again my
goal getting in this business was oh I
want to be the microwave cold sports and
I just well that'll be great
ha ha ha and that'll make me popular and
people will respect the fact that my
positions are unpredictable or they're
not tied to an agenda so yeah I'm
completely surprised that this is where
we've landed in American media where
again original thoughts a clause that
really challenge the establishment are
derided and are you know people social
media is trying to silence its play
because the being against the
establishment is supposed to be the cool
thing right that George Carlin that's
that's quite the power that's that's the
history of America is by power and
somehow now that's become not cool in a
bizarre way well well depending on which
way you look at it that the resists the
hashtag resistance people think it's
cool at the moment yeah but I don't know
if that's actually the power right and I
here's what'll get me in trouble
the resistance movement is actually an
establishment movement and they think
they're being anti-establishment but
Donald Trump is not the established
because that's what I was getting here
he is actually burning down the
establishment and the entire and again
AMA this isn't me taping up for Trump
but the entire resistance movement is
actually the establishment fighting back
against people that are trying to tear
down their cells yeah so let's unpack
that a little bit for the people that
don't get it because I feel the same way
that he's not yes he's the president but
he's not the full establishment when you
talk about the media and Hollywood and
the groupthink the things that were
allowed to say that's really the power
he's the one to take in the hatchet to
that right again whether you support him
or not without question and the other
thing to label Donald Trump is any type
of classic conservative is preposterous
he's not a conservative uh you know he's
a blowhard
that was a good TV personality a
successful TV personality obviously
successful real-estate person but mostly
a blowhard and you know he doesn't
represent any particular political
agenda other than uh you know he maybe
the agendas tell real estate
billionaires or whatever but I'm not
sure it goes much beyond that yeah are
you a conservative do you consider
yourself a conservative I mean I know
sort of what your politics are mostly
through Twitter in the show but uh
asking I don't want to reject the
conservative label yeah uh but you know
I've written for The Huffington Post uh
you know I'm anti guns
I think the Second Amendment is a farce
in 2017 so you would scrap it all
together yeah the second amendments a
joke really in my view I think that uh
you know the right to bear arms and if I
have a militia to protect yourself
against the government at all I think
made sense back when the Constitution
was written but unless we're all going
to have access to drones
we really can't protect ourselves yes
the government yeah I don't have any
stealth bombers anything but how do you
reconcile that or someone that obviously
is a healthy distrust of power uh yeah I
just think guns are unhealthy I think
that gun by I'm an African American and
when you look at the statistics about
who gun violence really impacts it's us
and so you know I I just look at the
stats and say you own a gun in your home
you're more likely to shoot a family
member a friend a loved one then you are
an intruder uh and again I get why
people like to hunt
I'm not against hunting and guns for
that reason but all the handguns that
are proliferated and all the
semi-automatic weapons and all the stuff
people are buying up preparing for the
end of the United States of America yeah
if the government decides they want to
take us out
they'll drawn tanks Delta's into
submission and our guns won't mean it's
a lost battle anyway
our muskets versus their versus their
drugs you've talked a bunch about guns
and the controversy that it has in the
black community do you think and but I
but what I find interesting is that you
do lay out some numbers I've heard you
talk about the numbers I mean not a
black on black crime and all that stuff
you get a lot of pushback on that right
yeah I just think that as an
african-american and keep in mind Dave I
lost a loved one that I was close to
that I helped raise spend a lot of
summers with me it was a cousin his mom
was like a sister to me growing up names
Anton Butler he was killed and me and my
families of you because of police
misconduct he was tasered to death in
the rain unarmed and so again the police
have a different narrative and you can
go look it up but this happened in
Indianapolis in 2012 I've been touched
by police misconduct paid for the
funeral shed the tears but I don't
believe my cousin
got in that position because the police
are out just to do indiscriminate harm
to black people I believe he got in that
position because of America's drug war
and mass incarceration policy and he was
a felon through his involvement with
drugs and that that vulnerability of
being a felon who had done time put him
in a place where he could be subject to
police misconduct but it is police
misconduct our real issue as
african-americans no it's not the
government is already highly motivated
to stop police misconduct because it's
highly expensive when the police kill
someone harm someone there are lawsuits
and there are settlements with the
family and the government does not want
to do that what the government wants
done is for poor people regardless of
color but poor people escorted politely
to jail if you escort them politely to
jail you can't earn a buck on them
you can make a profit the prison
industrial complex can eat off of
politely escorting people to prison they
don't want the police and there's all
kinds of things set up to prevent the
police from harming people and they do
it very rarely social media has
convinced us that this is the police are
just randomly out killing people and
it's just not true so I saw a video that
you did about the social media component
is that it confuses what the actual
stats are what the actual issues are
things like that you call them Seibert
with a cyber cyber human cyber human so
tell you a little bit about side rooms
because I talked about this idea I to
that that online thing is starting to
leak into the real world it's not even
it's not leaked it's their exact the
media we're addicted to social media
we're addicted to Twitter if you go look
at the stats the overwhelming majority
of Americans have nothing to do with
Twitter nothing it's not a
representation of what people actually
think in American society the media over
indexes celebrities over index you know
athletes people that are trying to build
brands or and people that are attracted
to people that are trying to fill brands
are the people that are on social media
and so because the media overindulge is
a social medium because we use it as
when our fingers all this is the way the
winds blowing because Twitter tells me
so yeah so if Twitter tells you that the
police are indiscriminately just killing
black men every night and the media buys
into that they will the media start
selling all unarmed black men killed
unarmed black men kill and they'll never
address the hundreds and thousands of
killings that poor people and poor
people color and black people are doing
to themselves every day that never gets
addressed there's no Twitter feed that's
popular that's out there telling you
who's getting shot in Chicago every
night every weekend and so there's no
hysteria around that they created a
hysteria
around when the police make mistakes and
or do something evil which is very rare
there's a policeman don't want to go to
jail not a good experience policeman
don't want to be the targets of the
vitriol that goes along with killing
anybody now are there some bad cops
absolutely but what is our problem as
african-americans it's the gun violence
we do to ourselves that's what's taking
us out and having a real impact and
that's what has our communities living
in fear I say this all the time my dad
was as black a human being as you could
possibly be he could afford to live
wherever he wanted he built a new house
in the ghetto because he liked being
around black people he had a business
that he ran in the ghetto because he
liked deal with my people when he put
alarms on his business when he put bars
on his business when he put an alarm on
his home when he carried a 38 every day
that I knew him it wasn't because of his
like jason maddox these police are out
to get me they may break into my home
they may break into my break that was of
it yeah it was he was worried about the
people in his neighborhood and the fear
and again he again to God love black
people
yeah but the reality of what's going on
in our communities there's not a
pervasive fear the police there's a
pervasive fear of ourselves there's so
many interesting layers to that because
we I mean just ten minutes ago we were
discussing gun control now you're
describing how your dad had a 38 and it
wasn't yet he wasn't using it to stop
the government from get him it was to
protect his own his own property into
Emily and all that stuff so so is it
just a gun issue so I've had a few
people out here that have talked about
how the policies often of the Democrats
have left the black community with these
sort of scraps that have sort of kept
them in that position do you do you
basically prescribe that I think that
yes I do
prescribe to that / - this far left
progressive ideology I think
is a shell game it's a trick it's a
mirage we tell you we're four black
people and we again I wrote in The Wall
Street Journal this week about a
President Clinton was an expert at
making black people feel he felt their
pain and he was an expert at creating
policies that intensified that pain and
so President Clinton loved us to death
but instituted and some mandatory
minimum sentencing policies some anti
drug war policy are some drug war
policies that contributed greatly to
mass incarceration which is crippling
black people so is that the issue there
that when you talk about these
progressive policies that they all kind
of sound sound great it all sounds good
we care about black people we care about
gay people we care about Muslim people
but the policies themselves when you get
down to it are a lot more complex than
just saying we're for all these
communities which is really just some
pie-in-the-sky stuff yeah I think that
again take let's take black lives matter
and I was saying this in 2015 I was like
man this black lives matter thing sounds
so great but it's poison and I would say
the Atman I didn't know Trump was
running for president in 2015 or
whatever but I was like an atmosphere is
being created for a trump-like person to
enter into politics and benefit from
black lives matter and and I say that
because I have a very dear friend in
Kansas City who's probably left of
Bernie Sanders and he and his wife
adopted brought in their home a
half-black half-white child they have
two kids already they adopted a kid who
basically need you know they had no
place else to go so again I'm trying to
tell you what kind of people they are
and when the situation at the University
of Missouri
rate with the kids protesting mimicking
the black lives matter out of st. Louis
and they cost the president at that
school his job all based off of he
didn't say this or microaggressions or
whatever it is yeah
my friend hardcore University of
Missouri Fair was like whoa what are we
doing here what and he had I wanna
pretty mother but he had questions about
black people and like hey well and I'm
telling you this guy loves everybody to
the left but the thing that happened in
Reverse in Missouri bothered him not to
the point that he would ever vote for
Trump but I was like whoa if this
bothered him oh my god what are the
people that are more moderate or
conservative what are they thinking
looking at this and they were thinking
okay y'all want to do this we're gonna
head to the ballot box and have a real
riot yeah you know I love the way you
frame that example because I think these
things are personal and they do come
down to those little moments and
agreement and they don't come down to
the Twitter outrage in the media outrage
and everyone's tuning out of CNN and all
that stuff because I would notice that
too when I talked I've talked a lot
about the college stuff yeah all that
and I get tons of email people saying
I'm a liberal but what the hell is
happening here what's happening to my
guy so when you make it about that
personal story that actually resonates
[Music]
you